you can make fun of the strange hat of a
pope or of a a bishop and you think that
that's funny but somehow you still
understand why you need a uniform to
play
sports you know it's like these are all
different levels of the same
[Music]
reality this is Jonathan Pedro welcome
to the symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
one of the reasons why it's difficult
for several people to understand
religion and religious behavior is
because they tend to want to isolate
religious behavior from other human
behavior and so they have this little
category here called religion and it's
broken off from all the other things
that humans do so because of that the
religious behavior Can appear arbitrary
superstitious ridiculous uh sometimes
also people want to reduce religion to a
set of things that you believe rather
than understanding it as a a coherent uh
you know set of behaviors and beliefs
that kind of go together I found that
the best way to understand religion from
a secularist perspective or from a even
from a a a purely materialist
perspective is to see it as an extension
of other types of behaviors and even I
would say as an extension or similar in
nature to some behaviors that animals
have and so uh one of the things that
I've noticed is that looking at the way
that an animals ritualize behavior is
actually a good way for humans to
understand why it is that we ritualize
behavior and what it is that ritualizing
behavior can do and
so the first thing to understand is that
actually all behavior is is ritualized
that is anything which is moving towards
a goal has to be ordered and so if you
don't like the word behavior let's just
use the word ordered so ordered Behavior
will happen as you move towards a goal
so if you have a purpose the things you
do you know will you'll probably
experiment a little bit at the outset
but at some point you'll realize that
you know if I want to get to the river
this is the best way to go at first
maybe I'll zigzag I'll do this but then
a trail will set itself up in the forest
to go to the river and then that
behavior going from the village to the
river for example will become ritualized
in the sense that it will become ordered
and will have kind of reduced itself to
its best uh to its best line you could
say to get to the river and so this is
something which happens in all types of
behaviors whether it is you know the way
to hunt or the way to prepare food all
of these will become ordered not like
100% ordered but there'll always be a
little aspect of variability on the on
the out on the margins but the behavior
will become ordered and so you could say
that when you order Behavior the more
you order it you do it in order to avoid
the cost of the behavior so you know
it's like if I I could get to the river
by going all around and going in circles
and doing all this and then I get to the
river and it's like okay but that's very
costly it takes a lot of time it takes a
lot of effort and so what I'll do is
that I'll start to order my behavior in
order to Res reduce the cost that it has
you know in terms of energy in terms of
time and all of that and in terms of
consequences you could say and so you
can imagine that this is something that
happens even in animal ritual Behavior
so think of for example ritualize
conflict between animals the animals
will ritualize their conflict and will
ritualize their capacity to recognize
who is the superior and who is the
inferior and they will do that to avoid
the cost because if they go all out and
they fight it out then that becomes very
costly both for the one that ends up on
top and for the one that ends up
submitting to the higher power uh and so
because of that we the animals develop
this kind of ritualized version of a
conflict which looks like a fight but
isn't complete does reduces the cost
towards something like meaning and we're
going to use the word meaning for now we
could use other words but purpose maybe
we could say is a good way to think
about it as you move towards purpose and
meaning and as you kind of Encompass you
know the reason why the fight is there
in the first place then you can
ritualize it in order to avoid the cost
all right so you can understand how
that's as true for going to the river as
it's especially true for animals that
will ritualize uh fighting Behavior or
animals that will ritualize a type of uh
mating behavior as well which is that
the animal will have certain certain
type of dance or certain type of colors
that will that will make the choice of a
mate less costly than it would if those
things weren't there like I said all
aspects of behavior are ritualized
they're just different levels of ritual
so you could understand that if you
extend that into the human sphere then
you can see how we of course do the same
which is that you know we've developed
shortcuts uh shortcuts of meaning in
order to avoid the cost of something so
a good example is when you meet someone
we shake hands we look into each other's
eyes we have found ways in order to
encounter someone in a manner that cuts
to the chase right gets to the meaning
of it which is that we're we're we're
meeting we're not in Conflict we we
recognize that there's a kind of peace
between us there's a certain level of
communion and so we've ritualized that
in the type of behavior shaking hands
all the other ones that that we have
which reduce the cost of figuring out
you know how who this person is what it
is that they want from me trying to you
know trying to move around asking
questions I don't know what type of
other types of behavior could exist in
order to figure out the intentions of
the person in front of you but you you
can imagine that that these types of
behaviors shaking hands and all this you
know was was uh was chosen out of a a
set of possible behaviors that were
maybe a little more costly okay and so
as you move towards more and more
contracted Behavior what you do is you
move towards something like meaning and
so what happens in that type of behavior
is that what happens in religious uh
rituals especially those that we
consider religious is that the meaning
becomes more and more uh compressed and
more and more pure more and more
crystallized which is that you know if
there's a manner in which let's say we
eat together as as a as a people and so
we come together we eat together and
what that does is it binds us together
as a people people we we noticed that if
we eat in a certain manner together if
we sit together on a table or whatever
there are multiple ways to do it but if
we aim towards that purpose there's a
limited amount of ways that we can do it
that it binds us together that it makes
us also share in the in the food makes
us share in the identity makes us
recognize each other as one for example
then we realize that wait a minute if I
can scale that up and so if I meet
together with my family or with a friend
and I eat you know that does something
but if I have like a banquet at the city
or or a marriage banquet where we all
kind of come together or some ritual
where we're it's a bigger meeting let's
say we have a a banquet to celebrate you
know the the 30th Anniversary or the you
know 100th anniversary of a city then
all of a sudden we realize that this
type of behavior these
ritualization of of Ceremonies of coming
together bind us together towards higher
purposes and so you can understand then
at some point
people inevitably started realizing that
the more you ritualize it and the let's
say the higher you aim the more it binds
reality together and so religious ritual
is an extension of the lower rituals or
lower behaviors all the way up so that
you're like oh wait a minute if I offer
this up to God if I offer this up to
something which transcends my group or
transcends you know the the the things
down here then I am in some ways uh
bringing together all these little meals
let's say let's talk about a sacrifice
of food all these little meals together
and so I'm giving you I'm pouring out a
libation or I'm giving up food to to to
the ancestors or to the gods and when
I'm doing that especially think about
the ancestors for example is a good
example it's like if I give something to
the
ancestors then I am doing more than if I
eat with my parents because I am binding
ing myself to something which is bigger
something which holds us all together
and so if I kind of play that out at
some point you realize that giving up to
the gods giving up to to to
principalities which are higher above
whether it is something like paying
taxes to the king that if I pay taxes to
the king then it binds us together as a
society uhhuh but if I pay taxes to a
higher level if I take my my things and
I bring and I give it up to a higher
level then it it basically binds me up
higher and higher and you could imagine
you can see how people realize that at
some point that kind of moves up and up
towards more and more meaning until we
reach something like the infinite source
of all things right the Infinite Source
which is the the you know the god that
is being and non-being the the god that
is the that is love which binds the
universe together you know the manner in
which the monotheists start to talk
about omnipotence omnipresence all of
these infinite qualities which end up
binding everything together and so if I
act together with
others you know towards that then I
realize that it's an extension of you
know paying taxes to the king and and
and also you know binding together as a
family but also even within yourself so
it's important to kind of see how
ritualization in terms of religious
practice is has to be seen in uh let's
say the the scope of all other types of
behavior which are ordered now once
again as I say this you have to remember
that all behavior is ordered and so it's
not like religious behavior is ordered
but this other regular Behavior we do is
it no that's not true it's like as you
move towards religious Behavior it's
more and more ordered more and more
containing meaning and as you move to
the more common space then it is ordered
maybe less and the tra tradeoff is the
trade-off between meaning and power or
meaning universal meaning and
particularity that's the way to
understand the trade-off and sometimes
you actually need to make that tradeoff
it's not you know if you ritualize
brushing your teeth in the same way that
you ritualized the Eucharist or you
ritualized a sacrifice to to the gods
then then you would lose some of the
particularity and so you would it would
actually become a it would actually not
be the right fit of ordered Behavior and
the thing you're doing a good example of
this a good example to understand this
is to understand the way that martial
arts uh develop themselves so you can
imagine that martial arts start as
fighting right you people are fighting
fighting and they realize that if I
order my fighting if I if I have a
technique then I can beat the other
person because I'm kind of I'm I I am
Contracting my Behavior towards a
certain thing but then there's also a
meta thing which starts to happen which
is that if I understand certain rules
certain ways of doing uh martial arts
then I am also going to limit the allout
cost of fighting you know just even very
similar to the way that animals
ritualize Behavior so people notice that
in tribal Warfare for example there is
Extreme ritualization which means that
there's still a fight but often the
fight because it's so ritualized it will
avoid massive massive casualties because
the ritualization you know and and it's
kind of not even doesn't even have to be
conscious people just kind of learn this
behavior and perform it the
ritualization will be able to show who's
winning the fight without completely
decimating everything so you can imagine
that even in the world of martial arts
that will happen where certain behaviors
are there to manifest you know uh it's
say a kind of Imagine like a knight's uh
the way that the Knights had uh certain
ethics about fighting it's like the
gentlemanly way of fighting right you
don't hit someone in the back you know
you look at them in the face all of
these types of behaviors are there to
avoid the massive cost of fighting and
push it towards more meaning but still
keeping within the the the arena of
beating your opponent now you can
imagine that in the world of martial
arts especially in Asian cultures people
started to notice that you if you
ritualize martial arts more and more it
can become it can Encompass more and
more meaning to the point where it also
almost becomes a type of ritual Behavior
where it it is almost metaphysical in
the way in which the movements are
capturing more and more meaning you know
if you think of uh of putting DS
principles into certain Kung Fu uh Kung
Fu moves and Kung Fu uh forms all of
this is happening and so it moves
towards more toward W more meaning so
that actually at some point the martial
artist is transforming himself he is he
is learning about reality he is moving
towards higher and higher meanings as he
is practicing his martial arts
now one of the things that happened in
the 20th century is that somebody
realized that that in terms of
power it was losing power as it was
moving towards ritualization so if you
look at what the MMA fighters did is
that they said no forget all these forms
forget all of these these these flighty
things that you're doing when you're
prepar when you're doing your your
Martial Arts forms it's like get to the
cut to the chase use what you need to
use in order to beat your opponent and
so what happened is that they the the
the MMA fighters were able to make a
tradeoff between ritualization and power
and they move towards power now this is
something which is there's nothing it's
like it's not that one is better than
the other to be honest it's just that
it's a trade-off between ritual and
power so think of an animal imagine now
in the world of the animals where the
animals have a ritualized behavior and
they understand and they're they're kind
of dancing where one person show you
know that I don't know the wolf shows
its neck and the other one kind of comes
and kind of puts their their paw on the
other and and to show that there one is
submitting and the other is dominating
now imagine if there was one wolf who
was smart and said man forget all this
rituals it's like when the other wolf
thinks I'm down and I'm showing my neck
and and he's put his paw on me I'm just
going to go for the
throat and that wolf would win in the
moment that Wolf by breaking the ritual
the ritual would actually increase his
power tremendously and so the and so but
what would happen is of
course that would also lead to to uh uh
let's say in the long term if if a lot
of a lot of wolves did that it would
lead to the allout conflict between
between the wolves and so so this is the
same thing that happened with MMA and by
the way with MMA you end up having now a
new ritualization which is that as you
move towards more power you have to have
rules in the fight because obviously you
don't want to kill your opponent and as
you move towards power that possibility
of just killing your opponent with one
hit or in the right doing the right
thing to kill your opponent becomes more
and more possible so the the type of
ritualization that happened in kung fu
or in some of the in some of the more
ancient martial arts gets re in
capitulated in The Meta rules of the
fighting game which is that you're not
allowed to do this you're not these
things you're not allowed to do because
you're just going to kill your opponent
so the ritualization reestablishes it
itself in another way but what's
important to understand is mostly to see
just how it is to think of to understand
just this relationship between ordered
Behavior moving towards more meaning and
then finding the balance of order and
power you say in a behavior in in order
to accomplish what it is you want to
accomplish and if you do that then you
can understand everything from brushing
your teeth to going to church because
all of these ordered behaviors kind of
Stack Up and scale up towards the the
Transcendent towards the infinite good
that binds the universe together then
all the way down to when I'm learning
something new and I don't know how to do
it and so I'm experimenting and I'm kind
of fiddling you know I'm trying to
figure it out so it's messy and it's and
and it's uh it's experimental and then
when I figure it out I try to order it
at the right level so that I can
accomplish what it is that I need to do
moving towards the purpose of what it is
that I'm doing and so hopefully this is
helpful to kind of help you understand a
little bit how ritualization works and
how how it is better and it's more
productive for us to understand religion
in relationship to all the other
behavior that we do rather than
isolating it when we isolate it then we
we we we just look at these weird types
of behaviors and these strange hats and
and you know strange costumes and we're
like What You Know What's the what's the
point but if I can tell you that you can
make if you you can make fun of the
strange hat of a of a of a pope or of a
a bishop and you think that that's funny
but somehow you still understand why you
need a uniform to play
sports you know it's like these are all
different levels of the same reality and
why you would want the policemen to wear
a strange hat because you want the
policeman to be recognized in his role
as an authority but you don't think
that's weird but you think that that the
pope wearing a funny hat is is hilarious
and superstitious and ridiculous that's
how if you were able to connect all
these things together then you'll be
able to understand more appropriately
why it is that religion looks the way it
does so hopefully this was helpful uh to
understand this to understand things and
don't forget folks uh you know if you
love what we're doing if you appreciate
what we're doing please consider
supporting the symbolic world at the
symbolic world.com we've been growing
quite a bit in the past few years you
know I now hired several people
full-time to kind of do this and so all
your support is there to make this grow
as much as possible so thanks everybody
and I'll talk to you very
soon next year February 29th to March
2nd we're going to have the very first
symbolic World Summit in Tarpon Springs
Florida a lot of people involved in this
sybal R Community will come together to
explore how we can recover the ancient
Cosmic
image to further this community and to
further this type of thinking in the
world